as a mother you don't really seeing it
until somebody comes and tap you and sit
up that young man is going to be a star
one day
Tristan Thompson breaks his silence on
his mom Andrea's death and takes a
moment to apologize for his wrong
decisions and this is all interested
it's not the draft ball the drop hats
the first contract pen oh I am so proud
on January 6th it was reported that
Andrea suffered a heart attack and died
on the one month anniversary of the day
she died the NBA Pro shared an emotional
tribute including a series of photos of
her he writes quote dearest mommy in
heaven it has been one month since
you've been gone I'm in disbelief I'm in
the deepest part of sorrow and grief he
adds that his soul is empty as he comes
to terms that one of his biggest
supporters and superheroes is gone
White House my mom are we having a
beautiful time
it's all such an honor Kristen also
acknowledges his faults with an apology
and although he doesn't specify what
he's sorry for he frequently made
headlines for his repeated infidelity
including fathering his son while he was
in a relationship with Khloe Kardashian
with whom he shares daughter true and a
son whose name they have yet to reveal
was Tristan going to tell me if there
wasn't a baby involved absolutely not
and that shows a lot about his character
the entire thing is Despicable quote all
I can say is I'm sorry Mommy for the
wrong decisions I've made in my life I'm
sorry for the embarrassment and pain you
raised me better than what I was able to
show you but I have also learned sorry
is not enough actions speak louder than
words stay tuned to the ways that will
show the world what an amazing son you
raised I'm going to make you proud I
promise seeing her do that and being
just like a warrior and a champion how
much she was willing to sacrifice for me
so I can go play and do something that I
love
it just shows her love and passion for
her kids interesting's tribute he also
promises his late mother that Amari his
16 year old brother who has epilepsy is
going to be taken care of first you have
to have a lot of love
lots of love because it takes patience
and understanding
for what you why you're going through
this
and then um to take care of our epilepsy
child
it's a lot of work but for me
I know
is my child so all the love that I have
I have to give it to him quote I'll
protect him love him and do anything in
the world to make sure he is okay when
it comes to his family he makes sure
he's a family man
[Music]